[Music]
is it just me or is internet culture the
trolling the outrage and the endless
hate starting to eat itself
this election obviously brought out the
worst in almost everybody from real
people to Twitter eggs and anime avatars
people are constantly attacking others
online and saying things that they would
never dare say to someone's face in real
life the really scary part of this
though isn't the words you guys know I
love free speech but there seems to be
no bottom to this hole of anger just
think about your Facebook and Twitter
feeds for a moment are they enlightening
interesting and bringing joy and
goodness to your life or are they an
endless cascade of rants and raves
psychotic ramblings endless fighting and
non-stop virtue signaling I'm gonna go
out on a limb here and guess that for
most of you the answer is the latter not
the former and yes there are also a lot
of baby pictures on Facebook which can
be quite annoying what I think is most
interesting about our constant state of
bickering isn't the obvious fact that
the Internet can bring out the worst in
all of us but that it seems to me that
this behavior and the reaction to it is
now bleeding out into the real world I'm
slammed with emails every day in which
people explain to me how they're
suffering real-world consequences for
what they post or even what they don't
post online people are getting fired
over tweets losing friends over Facebook
posts and god only knows what's
happening on snapchat but perhaps worse
than all of this is the chilling effect
that this state of outrage has on the
rest of us this is why I've said it
before and I'll say it again the biggest
threat to free speech is that we are
actively silencing ourselves not that
the government is silencing us the
threats of free speech isn't just that
protesters are violent at a Mylo event
it's the trickle-down effect that that
has now they're violent at events for
people like conservatives and
libertarians such as ben shapiro and
charles murray but of course it won't
stop there either eventually they'll
come for liberals too while at the same
time plenty of other people who just
won't want to deal with the threats
simply won't accept invitations to speak
in the first place the outrage machine
will just dull us all down to the point
where we won't share any original
thought
we just won't want to deal with the
repercussions this is exactly what's
happening with Trump right now the
mainstream media and the Twitter Brigade
go bananas every time anything happens
the result is that people won't be able
to gauge the proper outrage if he does
do something that truly warrants it yes
he eats his steak with ketchup while it
is well done that sounds horrible to me
but you've got to deal with it
remember the boy who cried wolf well now
we've got the media who cried Trump you
think I'm being alarmist here well do we
see more politically correct or less
politically correct than five years ago
what about ten years ago do you find
yourself censoring yourself more or less
now than you did even last year who is
forcing you to censor yourself is it the
government I don't think so I bet you
need only look in the mirror and guess
what this creep of stifling speech for
fear of being ostracized isn't going to
magically reverse itself we have to
proactively fight it and we should have
started this a long time ago take a
minute and think about our current
television programming could all in the
family arguably the best sitcom in
television history with a bigoted yet
lovable Archie Bunker possibly be on
network television today the beauty of
Archie was that we all know someone like
him whether that person is white brown
or blue only through seeing these people
poking fun at them and showing the
shortsightedness of bigotry
can we change our society to be more
thoughtful and decent for everybody even
when I watch Seinfeld with all of its
quirky racially based characters jokes
about gays women and everyone else I
think that the authoritarians will come
for the show about nothing which was
really a show about everything one day
as well it won't be the government
kicking Jerian and the crew off the air
it'll be the next generation of social
justice warriors upset about the episode
where George wanted a black friend or
where Kramer wouldn't wear the AIDS
ribbon or the ones with characters like
ping the Chinese delivery guy or Babu
the Pakistani restaurateur beyond the
outrage machine there is another
nefarious layer here which is a whole
group of people who get off on the
outrage itself
this is the group of people who react to
anything and everything so to get clicks
and ultimately money from our constant
state of outrage
so in pewdiepie makes a stupid joke
about jews as they did a couple weeks
ago the bigger reaction is from those
who want to capitalize on the moment
rather than those who are actually
outraged by the joke itself then the
mainstream media gets involved with the
wall street journal writing about the
incident which subsequently led maker
studios to end their contract with
pewdiepie this destructive force will
take anyone down who has moved up too
far the youtubers attacking pewdiepie
wish they had his fifty five million
subscribers and the wall street journal
sees how his influence Believe It or Not
is now dwarfing their own as online
culture gets woven into every facet of
our lives it's vital we all pick up and
choose our spots when to fight and when
to be outraged if we're outraged at
everything then we're outraged at
nothing if we spend all day online
trying to find enemies well then guess
what
enemies will present themselves making
some intellectual point over an opponent
has value but we have to be careful that
the value isn't because of the retweets
and the favorites it Garner's I'm sure I
could be better at some of this myself
by the way especially on Twitter trolls
are always gonna troll but those of us
who want to change things for the better
have to actually be better ourselves
final thought I was a guest on the Alex
Jones live show last week as some of you
may have seen I'm not even fully
familiar with Alex beyond the little
bites I see of him screaming and
generally going nuts that said the guy
has a huge audience and is clearly
influential as mainstream media crumbles
and online media Rises as I've said
before this comes with both positives
and negatives but regardless the fact is
the guy's talking to a huge amount of
people immediately when I got the
request to be on the show I thought that
I shouldn't do it because of the ton of
hate that I was about to get then I
realized that if I didn't do the show I
would only be holding myself hostage to
the very same ideas which are silencing
so many other people right now so I did
the show with no preparation or advanced
questioning and Alex let me say what I
wanted to say well I got the usual hate
from the usual haters just
appearing on the show I also know that I
got some of the ideas that I care about
to be heard by his large audience now
maybe some of them will come here and
learn more about the issues that you and
I care about if you're one of those new
viewers welcome I don't yell as much but
I think you'll dig it around here but
for the record I do not believe that a
secret group of lizard people are
leading a shadow government which is
trying to undermine our freedoms
obviously it's actually a group of frog
men led by Pepe and they're actually a
bunch of freedom fighters good luck to
us all
[Music]
you